so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys uh i am thomas dobas
whatever you want to call me this is the
dope as usual podcast this is my
producer slash co-host marty o'neal
folks we're back we're back for another
episode and this is a special episode
guys one that i like i told marty last
season we got to get them on but we will
have multiple episodes with these well i
can't even say these brothers because
your brother's not here right now but
this is the episode guys i've been
waiting to show you guys i talked about
this a couple months ago this is payaso
or terence whatever you want to go by
now since you're legal and professional
right we'll go we'll go
terence payaso route first square that
sounds good
yeah really esquire
oh my god oh jesus um thank you for
being here thank you for coming thank
you for having me um for everyone out
there
i know a lot of you just went what for
real on the show and for those of you
that don't know what's going on please
tell people what you do in a nutshell
what i do in a nutshell wow it's uh i
grow a lot of weed
that's great i grow a lot of weed i've
been growing a lot of weeds since uh
since for a while
for a while for a while
um
yeah for a while but really got into it
in the past you know 10 years
since you know 2012
really went heavy quit the job and just
said [__] it i'm gonna grow a weed
what'd you do before i was a pipe fitter
sprinkler fitter really you know the
fire sprinklers that's 15 years man i
did not know 709 uh union uh pipe uh
sprinkler fitter yeah really i don't
know so if all this fails i can go back
to that [__] yeah it's never gonna fail
no it's never gonna fail but and pipe
fitting is never going anywhere so
you're fine they make good money
i had never thought to ask i always
assumed it was just weed your whole life
i never even thought to ask you me and
my brother phillip okay oh say so real
quick i didn't know this i've known you
for
eight nine years yeah i know your
brother's name's phil yeah i know your
name is terence and i have never thought
of terence and phillip ever never have i
put those together
and this is this is if you saw his
brother be like wait stop you guys tell
me their names your parents phil
stop that full tatted neck his name is
terence
yup it is it's the mexican south park
man dude that's amazing and you said
your homie knows the writers over there
yes are my my well we call him the pope
but he's the head man over there at uh
wcc
and he's uh he knows the writer is
[__] hilarious and he couldn't
believe it when terence and phillip like
[__] we got to make the the growers
south park or just have you guys walk in
yeah
so two tatted terence and phillips
talking about it they would do that like
a little easter egg yeah that's you got
a [__] chance of that happening yeah
it's a shot yeah for sure
so you in a nutshell you've been growing
weed so let's we'll circle back on that
yeah let's get into
the pre-selling weed where were you i
know you're out here but where were you
born raised where'd you go to school all
that um i was born in cerritos uh
cerritos yes um
went to uh catholic school
when i was one through eighth grade
yeah it's it's called st linus in
norwalk
so i went to that for a year barely made
it barely made it yeah
nearly made it all by the needle and
thread but we made it and then uh after
that i think after that [__] life just
went [__] haywire wait from 13 yeah
that's when
yeah it's my life changed too but what
happened what were you as a kid just
normal kid doing your thing do normal
kid doing my thing you know [__] and
then just at 13 it went all bad
got into the neighborhood i was gonna
say the neighborhood took over yeah yeah
got into gangs and [__] caught a case
at 13. oh really caught a case at 13 did
a little juvenile all the time
and then just went from there and went
crazy really i didn't even know about
that yeah all bad yeah
juvenile from there with yeah juvenile
hall did a couple you know
little time in juvenile hall came out
went back to school then that didn't two
last
went to cerritos high for about a day
for about a day for about a day right
went got busted at a juvenile at about
the ninth grade
got out
my parents ended up sending me to
whittier so i went to whittier a school
called la cerna in whittier i don't know
if it's a school in this lasted about
eight months there
and then went to ended up moving to my
pops's pad in chino hills
i went to school a little bit like six
months at don lugo
and then uh that's it so yeah i had no
idea about all of this hold on no one
does you're getting in a hell of a
trouble power trouble hella trouble i
didn't know how did you get in trouble
when you guys were grown yes that's what
i thought you guys were starting to know
yeah i started getting in trouble like
planted my first seed i would say about
17 in mom's backyard oh okay so that's
where you started growing yeah yeah and
my brother was i'm 17 so my brother was
she's three years younger than me
and then that's when we planted our
first scene at mom's backyard because
mom mom had the greenhouse
so mom was always into exotic plants you
guys had in your blood he had had it in
the blood so there was always pots there
was always soil yeah you see you can see
we had the seeds we were like [__] it
man we started speaking of seats yeah
here's some joke here's a joint let that
show oh my please jesus save my life
really's gonna wait to start our own
show because yeah we always have to wait
to start our own show i like that
so what were you were you just being
reckless like totally reckless
totally [__] reckless out of control
just you know terrible terrible put my
mom through a bunch of crazy [__] but
mom was always there for me no matter
[__] what yola nice i mean bailed me
out of jail i don't know how many times
no matter what i was i was her angel you
know what i mean and i was just it was a
bad [__] situation are you the oldest
kid yes i'm the oldest how many brothers
has you got so i got one brother three
sisters i met the three okay i thought
yes
yes there's my brother phillip i got
alex paulette and cruzan
they all work you guys all work together
they all work together my two sisters
yes it's it's it's yes they kind of keep
me and my brother in check oh they told
me yeah yeah they're like oh make sure
they're [__] up
i got you
so hold on so you're getting in trouble
you're getting out uh 17 you plant your
first seed your mom's still helping you
out no matter what and she said hey
did she know you're growing weed because
that's the first little bit the brown
[__] so we would hide it we
would hide it on the roof
we had a roof a skylight we would hide
it on the roof we had plants
all over the house that's [__] smart
the skylight's a pizza because all the
sun my brother came up with this because
all the sun you know when sun rises
[__] hitting the top of the roof no
matter what's coming from they eat you
know what i mean so [__] we had plants
to think why would i i would never like
my king
i would never think that stupid question
can you fry a plant can it be like too
hot for you oh of course easier of
course yes definitely
so you guys grew it on the roof did it
come out yeah it came out fire come on
and then we would hide it because
helicopters would come to looking for us
so we would have to get up there run it
hide it run it around all over the
backyard it was yeah it was for your one
plant for about three or four in the in
the backyard oh all over the backyard
you know what i mean two on the roof one
in the back corner one over here
commando growing literally gorilla
growing at that point yeah would your
mom been pissed she she discriminated
against she kind of knew
but let it just
i mean she's bailing you out of jail
yeah that was kind of just go she was so
focused and busy
trying to raise
pay the bills yeah right mom would jam
at four in the afternoon wouldn't get
home until one
she worked in the bingo club in hawaiian
gardens oh so mom my i was in charge
right so mom took off [__] i ran the
whole house i had [__] what 10 hours
12 hours to [__]
[__] homies coming over [__] that
was the spot oh my god it was a spot and
then yeah it was a spot
okay seventeen you grow your first yeah
and that's your like uh we sell a weed
before that yeah and then we just
started you know i i
had a i had a guy named marco that came
in this is miami 91 92
it was called the afghani it was the
[__] fire 550 an ounce [__] right he
was he was fronting it to me he was
fronting it to me for 5600 on the cuff
and it will pee for a pee and it would
get delivered in a tupperware a
tupperware container not even in turkey
bag is it fire compared to now oh it was
super fire still still to that day back
in 92.
super fire
oh i would oh my god and then i would
break that down right of course you
should make it seven
and then i would wait i i would weigh
the ace you know eighth weighs three
point five three five
two seven oh
two seven
right and then i would make about 10 or
12 ace
roll them up and take them to the park
because where i live
there was a park and i would sell ace
for [__] 60 bucks
right 2.7 you're making an extra [__]
oh how how old are you when you're
making this money [__] 17 18 19 20.
yeah
yeah and then you know [__] the picture
on your box if you're for those of you
out there see oh let's say this right
now cannabis brothers that's the brand
that's the brand we're talking about as
you can tell on his chest and head the
cannabis brothers okay obviously for
terence and phillip south park the
mexican south park mexican style park
this is your guys's brand on the back of
the box when you guys first started i'm
not sure if it's still on there
it's a p it's an old school it's a black
and white right yes black and white it's
a huge outdoor grow plant in a bat is
that your mom's back that's mama's
backpack oh my god there's two [__]
young ass kids yeah my brother
they're both like that
they're just a huge plant it's like
that's the coolest box that might have
ever [__] seen yeah we and it's crazy
because mom at the time we were coming
up with uh packaging right and mom's
just out of the blues [__] send that
and once she sent it to to me and my i
think we had a little we have a group
chat she sent it to the group chat
and my i just immediately said that has
to go on the [__] box so tight so
it's just like oh this tells a whole
story one picture yeah one
one picture by oh i can tell everything
about this brand from the next to this
day i don't see on the legal side of the
market i don't see a [__] box like
that no yeah but there's not a lot of
legal companies out there that have like
uh tell the story it's all behind it too
yeah you know it's very rare yeah but
there's there's some yes yeah so 17 and
um
growing packs you get i mean you're
growing pounds you start dabbling in
your brother's three years younger than
you so yeah he's got he's just [__]
but not even that he's got the path
you're just like yo no come yeah you're
little
but i gotta say that i used to always
get [__] beat
right by your bob my dad oh okay
every time we [__] up i would always
get the [__] i mean maybe one just cause
it's scary even now as older man no bro
he didn't he didn't he didn't dig this
your dad did you're dead did it dig this
pops if you're when you watch this i
know you [__] you didn't dig this and
i got whipped all the way till i was 18
years old for smoking weed and now your
dad's sitting here oh
yeah cool [__] smoking choice i know
you're dead he's a buck he bugs my old
lady [__] queenie for [__] if i
don't ask him because i know what he's
calling for he'll call [__] queen
imagine that i'm gonna call my son i
need some [__] weed
i'm not buying i'm not erased oh that's
why it charges yes
i give him the two sevens yeah
okay so hold on your dad didn't [__]
we know that's that's the most shocking
thing i [__] heard that i did not
think you know you can't [__] with me
his dad is that every [__] wool back
when the cannons cut for fun i saw his
dad every
every show yeah every just sitting there
this slick hair it was something i'm
like oh you're just kind of scared they
call him lechuga michael
what does that mean
the milkman
[__] the lecher mac he used to deliver
milk you know with the bottles okay i
didn't know if it was that literally
sounded so cute
the legend man mike yeah
[__]
okay so your dad didn't [__] a weed he
used to beat your ass that's shocking
yeah um
one time i called his [__] girl a
[__]
right i called her a straight [__] and
he came home and
[__] me up what age were you
[__] how old was i was still in shadow
park so i'm about 19. oh [__] no yeah i
bought 17 my bad 18 19. somewhere
between 17 and 19. right old enough to
fight back
oh my god it's an animal no no i would
just talk i'm just crying yeah
i knew it was coming right yeah so
after [__] the fifth success time i
already knew the routine and it's the
fear that you put in you're like i don't
care if you can beat my ass i'm to beat
your ass yeah oh and then my eyes would
be bloodshot
when he knew my eyes were bloodshot
[__] get in the room get in the room
you know what i mean but yeah dad was
screaming oh he made you go and then i'm
going to come and beat you guys that's
what mommy's doing to me that's just
scary yeah [__] yeah it's like yo yo yo
close your eyes
i need to know when it's coming whoa it
helps i don't know why but it helps the
eyes closed yeah it's so much worse i
usually just know it's coming so i used
to just ball up oh yeah i just covered
my wrists i always feel like if you
crack them yeah we're all gonna be mad
you're gonna have to pay for it they're
gonna beat my ass for the hospital bills
i already know it
quick question yes first time you're
smoking weed
generic question but i need to know uh
it's about 12 years old probably 12 13
with uh with a guy named uh lewis we
used to call him weeds
weedge he was [__] eating the
neighborhood
you know what i mean his name was lewis
and another guy named rick but ouija is
the first person that got me high
did you like it yeah did you like it oh
i loved it did you first time i smoked
like that's okay
oh i love it i didn't like wow
i didn't i didn't do crazy well but i
was high
uh is it a joint yeah it was a joint
yeah it was a zigzag it was a zigzag
yeah orange bag and then a lot of the
[__] steel brass [__] pipe
uh honestly bro back in the days you
don't want to you really want to know
what we rolled up to smoke the weed
bible
paper tin foil
oh yeah the pipe the l pipe the l pipe i
made it because you can do this at the
end i used to i used to roll it with a
pencil
oh you're a pro like a pencil right you
could do that roll it up and then take
the pencil out right
take the pencil out no i know i thought
my dad would do a little flip
do a little flip yeah on the end okay
and then pack the weeds it's the best
you have to have a [__] screen okay
just pinch it for your screen yeah you
just pinch it yeah
i didn't know that was the thing other
people did yeah i thought you did it too
no my dad did
you're dead
i know the [__] i thought he was on some
crack catcher just like diy he might
have been [__] no no
he had that brass brass [__] little
out of the wall with the tin foil on it
i'm like [__] oh yeah he's smoking bowls
yeah weed
that's that that's that old white dude
playing music
yeah too cheap to go to the [__] head
shop that's what it was yeah
honestly i don't think they were using
shops back then oh you're on the east
coast too it might have been like he
needs a well-known music maybe he
doesn't want to be like
back then i don't know who i saw on
marijuana
yeah your dad has to be probably older
yeah
headshot [__] we didn't have no head
he's from new york so it must be oh
definitely no
underground head shot mm-hmm
your dad probably was [__] what was
that though that was a musician so he
knows what the [__] oh my god papa was a
rolling stone huh yeah yeah
so the first day he ever spoke we got
high was 12 years old yeah about 12
years old it's just like a question i
gotta i always got to ask and my next
question
we kind of got into early but i didn't
even know you got in trouble as a kid i
was gonna talk about when you guys got
in real trouble when you were older that
was in my after my 20 like uh [__] my
20s i i believe
we could we caught a case for uh
cultivation right it was it was just a
wee charge correct cultivation
transporting [__]
what's the story what happened the story
was um
we were into serious
business back then gang
heavy into gangs
so what happened was at that time i
moved out of my mom's house in cerritos
i had a house in whittier right by woody
boulevard and broadway if anybody knows
where that is i had a house on broadway
right
but going back and forth to moms you
know my brothers still live there doing
that thing so my house gets raided for a
[__] damn
uh a handgun for a murder warrant right
one of my boys ended up uh
catching you know a murder warrant
they're looking they raid the house
one of my partners says hey calls me
they're all in your mom's house at the
time i'm growing in whittier yeah
i don't know we had maybe six seven
lights uh at the time oh and you know
we're all indoor
and this is a 96 95 oh you're a criminal
right now yes oh and then i'm growing at
the pad right
so my boys telling me [__] they're in
your pad they're in your path
i panic i call my bro what do we do
actually my bro was with me what are we
doing
so the plants with all the flower that
we're almost ready to chop we put in one
bag all the vegetative all the other
ones we trash
get thrown in another car
you know guns i had pounds i had [__]
all kinds of [__] at the house at the
time
take it send it in another car and i
send it to my pops house me and my
brother stay back to chop all the flour
that had all the
the buds on it i go you know what let's
just take all the shits that are ready
to be chopped take you to my cousins
which lived less than a half a mile from
my house literally less than a house so
we load everything up in that car in a
rental car
we jump in it bags of cars smelling like
weed we're crumbing down broadway
we hit whittier boulevard and there's a
[__] black and white on [__] at
the light sees me and my brother and
just automatically gets right behind us
and pulls us over that's horrifying
oh my god my brother has a joint i'm on
probation already for some other
[__] so i already knew i'm i'm done
and you're in gangs they're all right
i'm done you're [__] oh i'm done with
a hitman i ended up taking a two-year
deal doing like 11 months you know what
i mean on a two-year deal i ended up
going to prison my brother ended up
[__] getting busted with we all we
both got busted
uh he ended up getting out doing some uh
some other [__] he got out and he ended
up catching another case it was just all
bad
ended up doing a couple years for that
were you getting pulled over all the
time or was that
no back then you would get pulled over
just the way you looked if you had a
bald head and you were mexican that's it
you're getting pulled you're talking
about you're in like the heart of east
l.a with all this
i'm in whittier whittier southeast los
angeles which is whittier artesia
norwalk cerritos hawaiian gardens oh
okay i'm in that area but at the time i
had the pad up in whittier which is on
woody and broadway i thought you're
talking about the street whittier with
your boulevard yes okay yeah yes when
you're on broadway but it's in the city
of whittier it's confusing yes winter
boulevard goes all the way down to east
l.a [__] yeah yeah that's why it's
confusing yeah even montebello you got
montebello but yeah
they ended up going crazy what a [__]
yeah i was sitting there in the car with
you guys right now listen to the story
and let me tell you since we're talking
about [__] [__] i'm gonna tell
you when they when they raided mom's
house
this is how much
my mom is such a g
when they raided the pad at my mom's pad
they found like 16 different weapons
right
from my sister's room to my room to they
all yours oh yeah there were some yeah
they were me and my brother you're the
older brother so so this is like the the
next friday and you're the bad neighbors
you're the brothers
mom
they hit the pad and mom takes the rap
for everything and says anything you
find in this house is mine oh my god and
back then at the time when you got your
house got raided whatever was on that
warrant is what had to be in that house
so if they found something else in that
house they couldn't charge you
right right so they were looking for a
glock which never was found
and if they come in and see a brick they
can't charge you with that no not back
then that's insane so mom took it to
trial
right i'm already in prison mom takes it
to trial gets out on bail you know takes
in charge of the gun yeah all the guns
all the [__] mom takes it to trial and
beats the case gets thrown out did she
know the guns were there
yeah no
damn
not that many
she knew you guys were i had them under
my sister's bed i had it was all bad
damn you guys were bad oh we were super
bad oh superman man i know exactly which
ones you guys are so mom beat the case
on that one
wow yeah took the wrap this is the 90s
this is the 90s
95 she could have like just kind of
because i want to now yeah yeah if yeah
the scariest bug scary bro is the gang
banging all tied up in the weed cells or
are they no no that's just back in the
90s bro back in the 90s you know
nowadays i actually i don't even know
what's going on nowadays with a gang i'm
i'm on a different holder
your name's terrence yeah and
that's what you say now my name is
terence now now now if i see a bunch of
knuckleheads i smile hey how you doing
brother my name is you know yeah it's
i'm on the different i don't walk that
way no more man you know what i mean i'm
a different path
just life is beautiful
you know what i mean i love it yeah
came a long way because i would think
back then it's like you get a layer of
protection but it's also like it also
now you're drawing all this [__]
attention in another way to yourself
yeah like we had freeway rick ross on
here he was talking about he was the
only one who like wasn't
gang affiliated because then he could
kind of dip in and out of the different
gangs and [__] with the drugs it's crazy
because now that i know i i
to answer your question back then there
was different neighborhoods so different
neighborhoods with drugs is i had a
friend that i that that was with me his
family was from everywhere
all my enemies so
my friend tommy got his name was guy oh
and his family was from
different neighborhoods all his family
free from artesia norwalk chivas he had
family from all three and all three were
enemies right
either my neighborhood was enemies but
when i'm with him we got to we got to
roll through all the neighborhoods and
that's how we maneuver the wheel
you know what i mean maneuver the weed
and selling through different
neighborhoods yeah cause look at up in
if you're not i didn't know that there
was gang territories with drugs and
merced because there are oh yeah i i
didn't know i don't know philly i my
name's thomas
all right i sell pizza and weed right so
i didn't know about that and i got down
here and i [__] no news flash yeah
it's like news the block it's literally
blah blah blah yeah it's it's even legal
companies yeah even i mean not legal i'm
talking about like even like stores like
whoa these
i'm gonna get into it crazy but wow i
didn't realize how deep that [__] runs
so the gang yeah so i couldn't imagine
the night back to the 90s oh gee said
that [__] somebody walked in and
pressed him at the counter yeah
oh i believe over there i believe
someone walked you didn't pay your taxes
og said he took his classes off and the
kid ran the [__] out he's like it was
just some kid i wasn't gonna chase him
but like
what the [__] it's a store bro he's like
do you see the sizes recently this is
recently oh my gosh
don't do that to me i'm a nice person
man yeah i'm i'm legit now leave me the
[__] and just like you said
hey man like i'm life is beautiful yeah
that's he's like get out of your kid
yeah that's what you say he literally
called him a knucklehead that's exactly
what he said oh [__] [__] knucklehead
pressed me there's a guy with a gun at
the door
[Laughter]
he said he was a kid though he was
underage type kid so i guess it's pretty
wild right there oh yeah it's downtown
that [__] crazy right there yeah um
so since it's been a long time you're
doing all the pack [__] after you get
out are you still [__] with the packs
oh yeah oh yeah oh so right back i'm
growing back then after i got out
i was out and now we're hitting into the
2000s right 2002 to that era
oh we were getting hydroponics oh no the
canadian we're going to oh the bbc
yeah delivered right to the front door
in hockey
50 in hockey listen i would get 50
pounds
delivered on the cuff
on the cuff you're getting weed from
canada canada on the cuff
right into 50 packs at a time at 2 grand
100 captain and you're probably
following oh i was fronting the whole
world at four
at four at four i was doubling up
the whole world i went a thousand on the
streets [__] it was crazy back then
yeah i'd have thought that have been
going in reverse
no charlie the camera the weed is
right the bc british columbia bc get
delivered to my [__] front door oh
[__] 50 pounds that was the white dude's
name that brought it
[__] it actually was
uh his name was [__] peter i knew he
was something [__] idiot oh all
through my cousin's yeah he was cool
he's a [__] buddy he was a [__]
idiot
he [__] the whole thing off eventually
but you know what i mean
but it was going good for a while but he
ended up [__] the whole thing off
those customs don't [__] play i can't
either you got to be hey
to get through a different kind of a not
a mexican yeah
a canadian agent do that [__]
[Laughter]
and i bet you they left them with you
and you had a stack and you wanted to
get rid of them on the cuff and then
when i had the money i sent it in
[__] boxes you shared it back
one of my cousins that send it back if
you're allowed to how the [__] did you
stumble across a canadian connect
one of my cousins
really one of my cousins that was into
all kinds of [__] [__] alan yeah
[__] alan
yup
wow he was into [__] birds and
[__]
birds are flying that way birds are
flying that way [__] but yeah i
wanted to do one of my cousins yeah oh
[__] yeah okay that's cool yeah that's
[__] that's [__] sick though wow
that's a movie you got the canadians how
deep were you how long had you been
doing it at the point that you started
getting plugs in [__] canada and [__]
well
well i was already doing what we were
doing but when it was yeah
it's it's set up a different level yeah
that's what i'm saying when i when i
hooked up when we hooked up with [__]
one of my cousins my cousin al and he
brought this dude named peter and he was
he had the he peter had the plug
what did you need where you at what's
the address i'll i'll drop them on the
cuff wow all my [__] back
that's that's such a [__] truth oh my
god i brought a brand new suburban i
threw 22s on [__] yeah don't matter
oh my god had the glock in the [__]
door in the door handle i was out i was
out of control
slanging pounds of the bc
did people like that [__] people
with a kobe jersey on i'm assuming yeah
they loved it
definitely a raiders man marcus allen or
laos alzado or something you know what
actually was 37 leicester hayes
nice jersey yeah that's right i i just
feel like i could see
the will smith step out
maybe not a cortez i don't see you
wearing cortez's back then i actually
they were k swiss see that's something
else
i learned a lot of case with i knew it i
knew it
that's not you yeah
all right cool so 2002 you get out you
get the bc but connect he [__] it off
after a few years he [__] oh years
yeah it went off for a good couple of
years i yeah so that was it was a good
run
very good run that sounds great [__] i
had a bad pain in the morning yeah [__]
it was a good run random question what
music were you listening to in this
timeframe oh i'm on the gangsta [__] man
uh-huh you know nwa [__]
and you're out here too ice cube you
know what one of my favorite rappers of
all time i'm not gonna [__] you
spice one i just brought a spice one
yesterday yup spice one more this one
got a [__] uh
uh a five point one but i feel like
spice one the corner south central
cartel iced tea
i loved iced tea [__] we used to go to
iced teas pat with my cousin [__]
rudy rest in peace really yeah with dj
ace [__] uh right
when you guys with weed or something of
course that's why we're that's it and
when he was rapping and [__] yeah yeah
yeah when i stand here he was doing a
lot of the body count at the time and he
had the house up in hollywood hills he
just built the pool we used to always go
up there dude good [__] yeah yeah with
the packs man that's the time syndicate
[__] in yeah i mean people knew [__] i
had the afghani
the [__] i had the enemy
and the super skunk one so ever heard
that the cabrals go to the cabrals they
got the fire [__]
if you know if you grew up in that area
cerritos the cabrals always had the fire
that's so funny rocco's last name that's
my little brother's last one so wild
yeah um
but okay so i'm just trying to imagine
this you're dropping packs to ice tea
when he's talking about shooting cops
still
yeah all right
so you're listening to all this [__]
you're riding around you were fully
absorbed full of his life yeah yeah and
you said like i was going i was nuts
going hard video game characters yeah
yeah just going hard like [__] you
think about it today what i'd be
carrying a gun [__] no no
no [__] no are you stupid yeah it's just
i was on that wild [__] edge i didn't
give a [__] yeah you just i mean you
just got out and now you're feeling like
i'm [__] did it already i'm out this
is the grown guy [__] i'm out so now
you're out you're getting the packs of
the bc
that's being a sprinkler fitter at the
same time this whole [__] time and
nine yes so i i after i get out of
prison i i i have to get a job yes
so i didn't even trip out on this my
dad's been an [__] right
i don't talk to the [__]
i get out of prison
right the next i get out of i don't know
if it was that day or the next day he
calls me hey what's up doesn't even say
hey how are you doing you need anything
is good [__] it
what's up
i'm telling what you tell me what's
happening you want a job i go [__] yeah
i want a job go to this address at 7am
and don't [__] be late and just like
damn i am i go to the next day i show up
at 7am not late and it's [__]
uh sprinkler fitters union hall [__]
local 709
i'm immediately into the union with no
high school diploma yeah on parole
because his company at the time my dad
owned a sprinkler fitting company and he
said the only way he's going union if my
boys
are signed into the if they're accepted
into the union he's an [__] but he
set you up yeah he did set me up wow
that's a great level and became the man
we're a hard working [__] man i was
running a pipe machine at 15.
really yeah [__] yeah
so
working hard working up at five being on
the job site at [__] 6 a.m mm-hmm so
i i until to this day i'm up at 5 00 a.m
oh i wish i could have that oh i'm up at
5 a.m oh yeah i can't do it piss my old
lady off but i'm going to find him yeah
they get annoyed yeah they don't like
that [__] that [__] no those unions like
i noticed on set like the dudes that are
in the union for the uh grips and the
lights like they look like i'm like
probably a couple ex-gang beggars on
here bro
they got their [__] [__] down though
they're actually hard-working
yeah i mean it taught me how to work
[__] hard straight up work hard and
at that time being an apprentice through
the union it was like go get this go get
you know fresh out of the joint like
[__] you tell me i had to suck
it up yeah i almost got in a couple
fights with the foreman a few times but
you know being as a man yeah you suck
that [__] up and you learn and you
[__] yeah it became i i it be i i
became the man
through that trade yeah it's life that i
am today
yep that's what i needed [__] you should
do that for 15 15 years and me and my
bro yep my brother
yeah yeah you guys are [__] close man
you guys do everything yeah oh he's my
right hand man
i i asked her right he would have been
here he just he's not feeling good yeah
just going through some yeah he would
have been here that's why part two is
with him yeah yeah we'll have one back
and we'll have both of them on here nice
that we did it like this actually yeah
man i wanted to i wanted to have you one
i feel like people need to be exposed to
somebody that's been on both sides yeah
and not been on both sides like because
we have our like other homies that do
weed industry [__] of course but no
one's been on both sides it's like
before we started filming you go man
before i'm like
selling packs and doing [__] i have a
gun and now i'm
name's terrance and i'm doing conference
calls and figuring out [__] zooms and
yeah it's weird because you guys have
you're a full-on real company right i
want to pop into that right now okay
cannabis brothers when did you guys
start officially being because before
this wi-fi og that's what i know you
guys that was for yes that's where i
know you guys from definitely the first
time guys with rascal and [__]
those were the good ol that's that's
when we first met that's what he first
doing the high times doing the night
time times look back on some of the
first high times cup vlogs you guys are
in it yes definitely yeah we're in your
booth we're smoking with that you guys
met through the [__] high times yes
marty it goes back baby yeah man like
nine years yeah i figured it was just
through some packs or some [__] no
i was making videos actually um we talk
about high times how we got into the
high times with was with uh my boy besco
donnie really he's the one that turned
me on to [__] high times so so it was
me my bro rascal right og rascal
genetics just selling we we had a spot
we had 30 light spot and pomona [__]
you know growing the fire
in the fire at that time i quit my job
now we're in 2011 2012 right
rascal is from my neighborhood same gang
og rascal the one that created the white
fire
right that's my homeboy that's my
brother's homeboy we grew up we're in
the from the same neighborhood okay
white fire wi-fi yeah strains my brother
gave
rascal before he went to the prison o.g
kush which rascal changed that name to
fire og and created the fire white fire
with chrome's white
damn that's where it originated that's
an original originator from my brother
gave rascal the [__] cut
yeah and we were all home we're we're
all homies fact and [__] knuckleheads
and
my brother ended up doing some time my
brother got out [__] rascal created
the white fire damn and then at that
time rascal was like you know my brother
gets out boom you guys
and that time we we grew weed the whole
time right as we were going the whole
[__] time yes but then rascal got
into the do the breathing
so now rascal's doing the breeding right
and we grow the weed rascal's all my
brother gets out of the joint
my brother rascal says he gets with my
bro and says you know what let's get a
spot
[__] it and at that time at my dad's my
dad owned his business right
my dad calls me and says hey i got a
spot next door to the [__] in my
business
right [__] hangs the [__] up on me 5
000 square feet 5 000 square feet
yeah [__] we would blow it out i quit my
job with the union
get this [__] with rascal blah blah blah
blah we got 30 likes and we're banging
we're growing the fire yeah the white
bubbles the white fire the [__] the
bombshell that's when i met you guys yes
so that's the same time i met you guys
yes when you said that's the same type
of doing the
first cup it's the same my first cup
probably right 2012 was the cup we want
to cup it no the first high times and
then we won a cup in 14. because i met
you guys in 13. yes like right at the
end of 13 rounds first started push
trees yes and all that [__] used to
walk yeah [__] you had a crowd
everywhere you were walking around high
time this dude had a crowd of [__]
people around this camera the other day
and i used to just trip on like damn
who's that dude
i go we gotta [__] hook up with this
dude he's the man y'all is the man look
at this crowd following this yeah
it was like yeah it was like [__]
forest gump remember if you guys were
like yo i didn't ask i didn't ask any of
these people walk with me yeah no lie
marty there was like 35 people at one
point easy and i was i don't see that
right i immediately go to the booth
and tell i don't know who i told but i
said
let's get a [__] jar for this guy
immediately nice we put a [__] nice
cat couple fat jars and i think that's
when we blessed yeah somebody just came
made me wait i'm like oh thank you man
yeah i know what the [__] great way to
win somebody over not even that i was
like
excellent yeah
that's how i know we got to get this guy
oh [__] ladies
that's how i met him yeah
why and then my boy at that that those
crazy times were my first cubs the wi-fi
we got it to be real
the wi-fi at that time
so that's when i hooked up with jared
back then that this all the same time
same era i said i meant him yeah jared
yeah and jared took the wife why fire to
be real and then that's how we went to
the [__] show you know we were on the
show [__] um
forever ago that be real tv [__] [__]
yeah we brought rascal [__] [__]
seven plus years ago man easy yeah at
least at least right yeah so damn i
didn't know okay so i do remember he
gave me some jars i'm like you know
because it was one of my first clubs i'm
like you really just give me weed what
the [__]
in abundance
and i felt bad like
do i take it
i felt weird
and then somebody introduced me to him
later with chilling like all these folks
are [__] hi i met you i met your
brother i met uh your dad
there was um like two other fools that
don't work with you no more but they
were younger dudes mexican kid i think
he did like the hash or the the he
blasted oh the yes yes you remember him
i don't know i know you were talking
that's how i met you guys and he's like
yo let's meet and then in seattle when
we were chilling with dante remember we
were all smoking oh my god and then we
all started chilling and that's when i
met him for the first time at your booth
you brought memories in your face
right the pool and there was a big ass
tree right next to your booth yeah yeah
[__] we won a cup that time that's the
one you want to cut okay so that's the
challenge again that's the time i'm
talking about wow it goes back so far
[__] crazy right how time flies i
forget those are actual competitions
where people are winning dude bro and
those were good competitions when they
were real those were good [__] you
weren't [__]
paying 50 000 for the booth bro i gave
[__] for high times we gave him three
grand yeah for the blues we weren't
[__] sponsoring the whole high time
50 000 here to win 10 cubs no
because like cannabis brands weren't
such a thing they weren't those they
were
a lot of people were scared
oh when we dropped seeds so when we
dropped seeds at high times at that time
you can get in some serious trouble
right but the cop they used to go around
every booth there would be cops walking
around the cannabis cup making sure
people were not like selling packs and
or the main thing no liquor remember no
liquor i love that the cop came up he
busted through i had pounds in my hand
this guy busted through hey come here i
was like [__]
and he went by and grabbed his beer out
this girl's hands like throw it away
thank god fight cop yeah did that really
just happen
we were with [__] uh
ah who had all the packs damn i think it
was vic vic was showing me attacks
because the cop was like i thought he
was coming at me but that was the only
problem we have that's back when it was
real you guys were winning cups when it
was this is the post fire yeah we were
not like they donated so much we're not
going to give him a cup we got to give
him at least a second that's what it is
turned into social media or like no
social media's still going it was gone i
i started i think i started the buy also
grow instagram in 2012. okay it ran for
a little bit 2015 and then got deleted
for three years same
and then i
somebody told me how to [__] get it
back your brother got my page back once
yeah and then uh yeah uh uh uh
what what horosc's help me get my my my
page do you have your original page now
yes i got my written
2012 yeah
i mean it's shadow band like a
[__] i might be following the
wrong one i just had to leave it again
so okay
do you have two pages i think i think do
you have a personal oh we have one and
then we have one with my with queen
i've been trying to figure out this
[__] problem i was literally wanting
to fly over there
stand in front of that i drove over
there
in front of that office and say what the
[__] [__] yeah at this point yeah yeah
but you know what [__] it [__] it okay
you're hot like fire right now so it
don't matter doing our thing that gives
a [__]
hey what's up guys dope asioli here
we're just taking a moment to talk about
one of our sponsors and this is
expressvpn do me a favor guys real quick
go to expressvpn
that's
expressvpn.com forward slash yola when
you use that code at checkout that gives
you three extra months free when you
sign up three free months and i want to
bring you guys to a very relatable
example certain countries don't get the
same shows that other countries get on
netflix japan might get different
netflix shows than us so if you want to
see what japan's watching you can't but
if you have expressvpn you can say i am
now in japan and now your netflix will
be according to your location so with
expressvpn you have over 90 countries if
you want to watch french netflix or
german stuff you can but the us doesn't
offer everything this is just expanding
your variety and that's just one of the
many features that expressvpn has to
offer so once again if any of that
interests you at all go to
www.expressvp
forward slash yola that's the code at
checkout and it will give you three
extra months added to your subscription
so huge shout out to expressvpn for
supporting the dope as usual show back
to the episode
right yeah shout out to youtube in the
podcast and everybody letting us do our
thing shout out to miller [__]
like you brought a 12 pack by the way oh
this is called what am i doing
no he he walked in out of his car and he
went i brought marty a 12-pack
thank you thank you thank you appreciate
you being here thanks for having me
so let's get into this yes company
cannabis brothers when did you guys
start officially being legal officially
being legal was 2 000.
when did we get to arolanko babe
it's been that long 2018 we hooked up
with some dudes some dirt bags but
got us on the market
right got us on the market 2018 we
locked we were up in honolulu rocking
like 18 flower rooms damn
just killing it
totally about 400 lights [__] damn
brought this company to [__] it was
when we got a long story short we were
killing it right ended up winning a
couple things at two in 2019 at the um
secret sash or was it uh uh
the kush stock we were killing it you
know
and that's when we first went legal and
then yeah
2018. and you guys have been building
remember when we did the i think it was
hall of flowers yeah just walking around
with a microphone doing all that [__] if
you guys remember from that video yes
that's where i that's where you guys
probably recognized him from like that's
where the [__] i seen that logo from
that's where you guys saw it cause
remember you guys are in there with your
gigantic boxes yes
yeah
it was the eighth box blown up as big as
this table yeah with their pictures and
all this [__] oh [__] dope man
we killed it for 2018 2019 man it was
very quick and it was like no more no
more events yeah but that was the last
event i got to do before code happened
but you guys have been in stores you're
doing your thing and now what is the
difference between now you're not with
right now now now we're not with those
guys we had a fallout you know long
story short i'm not here you know yeah
bad partners not with him no more got
another partner after that bad partners
ended up [__]
just you know
this happened so we moved it to another
spot right after alonto we moved into
balman park with some other partners
this happened
by accident yeah
uh we had that for a year you know i was
down for about a year my brother was
holding down at that spot and as a
master [__] grower you need your
[__] hands i know it's detrimental at
the time it's probably i mean obviously
life-changing at that point thank god
for my brother because he he filled that
gap you know what i mean when i was gone
yeah so he filled that gap balman park
um
that didn't work out after i'm i'm i
recover come home [__] check out the
you know long story short that didn't
work out
my brother from uh west coast cure jared
yes you know there it is there
right here long story short we teamed up
with them
and here we are today so now you guys
are partners now we're partners we're
going to be running all their large
cultivations uh cultivations from state
to state damn you know what i mean
you're still doing your own thing too
we're definitely doing our own thing
we're all canada's brother's always
going to be cannabis brothers no matter
where the [__] we go but
west coast cure has a vision
that has a vision that's [__] out of
this world
me and my brother have the same vision
so those two aligned right
we aligned together
and they're we're
now we're we're west coast
conglomerate baby from a business
perspective like what what do you like
for somebody that would know nothing
about who west coast cure is or what
they do what do they do in the context
of like your agreement like is there a
huge
outfit
yeah they're like distribution would it
be called oh they're everything every pr
ever any marijuana product that's out on
the market west coast is involved and
now we're involved
it's a long story short is it going to
be your packaging still like no it's
it's going to for now oh so you guys are
absorbing and absorbing in oh so oh so
no you guys are the grower and now
you're partners partners gotcha
so instead of like yo this isn't working
this isn't [__] working like we want
if we're going to make them basically
what we're about to be doing kind of
with this yuck yeah we just deal what
we're talking about no we got to step it
up yep we can expedite this process
and and it's the relationship i got with
jared
is been phenomenal since [__] since
i've known you dude i met him before i
think i met you yeah he might have
brought me do the booth yeah
jared is basically like
the cannabis
what would you say the cannabis like
link in between entertainment
does that make sense that makes totally
sense he's like yo rapper guys yeah we
[__] with each other yeah i own a pretty
big [__] company yeah i'm gonna bless
you and you guys now smoke all our [__]
and then it just it was organic
marketing he was getting through guys
because they were smoking his [__] and
then they met you and now it's like wait
here we got better
so now i see why you're doing this yeah
this is like yo we could be independent
we could do great or we can be like now
we run mtv's creative department
and
[__] partners so this is like i get
it the highest
partners was [__] the guy
jared's vision is [__] unbelievable
and we hit it off like [__]
you know what i mean like chi chi chong
is there any advice
yeah you could give yourself stuff like
let's say you just got out you're
starting to get into the higher level of
business of this era of the cannabis
industry having gone through all the bad
partners and the accidents and stuff is
there any advice you'd give yourself now
to i'm gonna give my give advice to
anybody out there that's been going
through this crazy madness from the from
the legal side the non-legal side to the
legal side
keep
pushing don't ever [__] give up on
your passion and
especially if you love the plant
fight all the way baby because if you're
a good [__] person
right you do good you treat people good
good shit's gonna happen to you bro of
course it's just the way the world is
homie
god is good and if you're a [__] good
person and you grind and you love this
[__] plant stick with it no matter
how many times you get shot down
turned down
[__] you
keep [__] pushing
you know what i mean keep [__]
pushing message of the show man yeah
keep pushing it's all you could do close
to everything well truly truly it does
yeah so now you guys are going to be
running the cultivation like i said i'm
[__] learning how to work a computer
how about that you're not you're not
even touching plants anymore huh i'm
looking at a computer right now baby
whoa [__] your wife he's happy kids are
happy life is good my baby's on i got a
baby on the way oh i i heard yeah baby's
on the wall quick real quick yes
while you're doing all this
while you're doing all this while you're
growing while you're doing pipe video
can you i mean if you're comfortable
with it because marty always says three
kids
[__] three kids yo this shit's crazy
as hell i don't know what i'm gonna do i
gotta run i'm a [__] bus driver i'm
[__] trying to work driving and
stressing out right now yeah
how many children do you have
i got one
on the way
oh okay
i got one on the way
i got 10. total we
got 10.
but one on the way but yeah man uh
that's a lot of work it's a lot of work
marty three kids feels like ten i don't
know
i am truly blessed bro i got we got a
household of uh
six seven eight we got a household of
eight right now because some of your
kids have grown grown up and they're
doing this yeah i got my my oldest right
my number one
lorena
is doing the same follow my footsteps to
the t
from gang violence
to prison to to now right now she's
[__] killing it in a cultivation nice
good luck [__] has her [__] together
[__]
a1 i'm so [__] proud of her but she
followed my footsteps to the to the t
right babe
to the [__] t and right now she's
working in the garden in a spot in long
beach beautiful spot too
good yeah she's a badass nice that's
your first lovely girl firstborn my
firstborn whoo
when did you have her 94. it's been
young oh yeah you were young
oh yeah you're a young dad too [__]
man you had a lot to do yeah young dad i
went to prison
when i had i went to prison when i when
[Music]
i had her yeah damn okay so you're not
just traveling out here you're actually
having for everyone out there for the
backstory but i'm trying to make money
doing this yeah
i got kids yeah that's the day chappelle
[__] i'm selling weed
remember that [__] that's that's this
fall out here yeah i got kids yeah you
gotta [__] sell we to make it
you know i mean [__] i don't know
especially times the way everything's
spiking nowadays i don't even know how
you people [__] do it
especially these [__] gas prices
jesus christ well you came in here in
the biggest car of all time i know you
do have a bunch of people in your house
nevermind
we just bought this [__] truck
[__] 2021 suburban right
125 every [__] the way we drive what
three four days
damn i'm going downhill
i'm going downhill it's coaster
now i gotta convince we can get a tesla
right
[__] if you got the time yeah you got
the time to charge go for that [__] i
know you got the time i don't i don't
i'm an impatient [__] like crazy
damn so now you're sitting back your
name's terrence and you're on a computer
terrace and i'm on the computer would
you say as far as your actual growth
techniques are you still pretty old
school or do you use tech well we heard
our old school but i'm telling you in
this industry in the last three or four
years
[__] has changed
[__] has changed especially if you're
looking at large school large-scale
cultivation oh yeah you know what i mean
uh shout out to the guys from athena are
are helping us on all these new
cultivations
with equipment equipment irrigation
[__] you name it you got to think
about all the jungle boys yeah stuff
that goes in yeah people think oh the
weed you just need like light and you
know like you know how to do it no no no
all the [__] around
is unreal yeah
growing weed is so [__] hard
you figure you yeah it's it it's to
break it down like legally yeah legally
especially to get one plant say the life
of one plant legally clone you gotta tag
it well go go from there to that on the
shelf it follows every time once you
make that cut i believe it's after
seven inches that that plan is tagged
and then it's followed all the way
through its life's life cycle right
you know what i mean so it's
and the way
taxes
i don't
unbelievable
we need no taxes marijuana
uh it's it's
i feel sorry for it's [__] hard
going that legal route mm-hmm going from
the black market to the legal side right
you're used to so much oh my god how do
we survive they make you do a lottery
and all that they tapped you ten times
yeah what do they tax i mean
you know i i don't know a candy bar why
can't we get taxed why can't we get
taxed like a candy bar or [__] the taxes
[__] and then quarantined yeah and
then if your batch doesn't pass throw
the [__] room yeah get them not the
plant the room to trash the room don't
you know that i don't know about this
[__] right now if the nug doesn't
explode
you know the nug don't pass for mold or
[__] whatever the situation is
got gone you gotta that patch that that
whole thing because they said even
though it could have been one nug yeah
it could have been one nug on your grove
that happened to have something yeah but
that's it it's over your whole [__]
legal room is done but what do you have
to do that to destroy it right yeah
technically yes
this one
i'd be saying a hell of a room
my whole crop went up sir [__] mr irs
man
oh i never thought about that yeah
so when you like like when they test the
percentages like we've been having
hearing like little mini controversies
about this like how much oh perfect
leeway there is and what the percentages
can be and all this type of [__] and
like also taking it a step further and
saying like
the thc percentage isn't really such a
huge factor in the overall experience or
indica sativa it's really a combination
of all these different factors what do
you think about when you think of like
what defines the potency of a strain
defines the potency of a strain is
[__] [__] yeah i mean
that i don't know you know the test back
then did do you ever test weed that you
[__] no [__] no the oh geez you could
have that bomb og coming in at 2 you
know 19 or whatever the percentage rate
is and that shit's [__] gas oh yeah
it's it's a it's a different
time era you know you just
that's what that's what they're asking
so that's what you got to give you know
you got it
people walk into a store
they want to see that high thc number
no matt you know what i mean
that it's
it's it's it's crazy
but that might not necessarily be the
best factor no no no one that's like
saying damn 211 is my favorite beer what
about there's different
different things in that in that plant
besides tmg you know what i mean
but it it's just the way
the way that
the legal side is
yeah like if i didn't know what i knew
yeah i would ask the bud tender what do
you smoke that's the number one [__]
what's popular what's the most what do
people what what else 90 percent of the
people that walk into that store says i
want the most highest three what's going
to give me the highest yes but it's not
it doesn't matter though no it's
different it's like what's what what
like forms with you best like oh this
terpene doesn't [__] with you you always
feel weird about that it's not the thc
percentage [__] it's this this
and this
people
rely on thc percentages like they look
at alcohol level yeah you know i mean
like like 211 yeah
[Music]
yo that's the that's the beer of bums
and then in the 90s was everyone
everyone drink that [__] i was gonna say
there's another one i'll figure
steel reserve man that's where we were
stealing out of the [__] car
how about lucky laggers the beer the
lucky lady i don't even know what that
is lucky lagers never even heard it in
my life what the [__] nah came into
[__] lucky laggers
the cheapest beer on the [__] market
lucky lagers no
cheapest no lucky lager yo i'm i'm never
even heard of lucky [__] laggers bro
it must be awful terrible
terrible
so what do you think when you see like
the hey abby now are you like oh yeah i
just showed him like is that like it's
got to be astonishing right
what was it what the the grow box i
showed you oh my god the hey abby yes i
want one i know i told you i want one
yeah i just knew i thought it was
[__] cool as [__] it just looks like
a water cooler no
i could leave it with queen and then you
know you [__] it's like uh it's fine the
app says it's fine yeah the app
yeah that's that that's all you gotta do
but do you feel like from what i've seen
right now you the quick thing that you
showed me i [__] it
who wouldn't get one right are you that
stupid it's pretty [__] cool you
gotta really be stupid not to get one
because it's so easy
wow not endorsed in any way shape or
form make sure the numerators are right
and it it shows
itself it opens the door for you because
i knew i was like i'm going to show you
yes jesus christ
i told him i want one no real grower to
be like no i was going to show him and i
knew he's going to be like
well a little bit deficient right here
but it looks great it was a little bit
it's because i've never been there yeah
i was a day late i was a day and a half
late to [__] do it i told him i'll
take the nutrition you'll be fine yeah
snap that right out of it
you're in the water i just gotta drain
the water and [__]
i've been i've been filming a lot throw
some athena in there you'll be fine and
athena
what is that
is it nutrients yeah there's a bug
damn it sorry that's all nutrients and
what you guys use yeah
exclusively excuse me
really okay nutrients so you're you're
here now so basically
when we say go support you guys yeah now
it's here it's here
good job
yes so when does when does your like
when did this kick in so although
we've been
with them for about a year right i would
say about going on about a year what
about a hobby about a year i didn't know
no one did this is the this is live
the i mean this broadcast the whole
world is going to know now
what a lot of people didn't know right
they maybe see it on my page a lot but
you are i was wondering why yeah i saw
it lately i'm like huh and then we've
been laid back me and my brother haven't
been we've been laid back in the cut you
know but we've been working
so that's why you're coming yeah yeah
pretty soon we'll be [__]
oakland
uh
arizona
florida
sacramento we'll be somewhere
soon do you think that's what we'll do
part two the next five years do you see
a huge change like in our culture for
cannabis marty with the odd question
that's an excellent question marty the
next five years let me tell you it's
gonna be really rough
because you're going to have all these
big [__] companies coming in and
and if you don't got that [__] solid
brand and that solid backing
good [__] luck
damn good [__] luck being you'll be
drowned out you'll be i mean it's hard
bro
it's really [__] hard
you know what i mean
especially if you're coming from like
like me and my brother we came from
nothing we came from the trap we came
from
straw you know
it's rough it we came from [__] and
to hook up with my par my brother from
west coast cure is
is a dream it crosses you into where
crosses bring it with [__] marble or
yes now we're taking it we're
we're on the next because when the wave
comes yeah all that the big money the
trillions yeah you guys are still last
yes and you're like yes we can do it
we're true yes but we don't know if
we're and there's a story there there's
a story about i got me my brother got
our own story jared got his own story i
know both of you so it's crazy to see
that it's now two minutes [__] got
you know because it's been a long time
it's been past the statue of limitations
a very very long time yep
so i could tell i could the first time i
ever saw pax from you guys and jared was
grabbing him yeah oh he was grabbing him
oh he grabbed him like did you just say
37. he said yeah i'm like i'm from
merced i'm like did you sit three seven
oh yeah
yeah
oh my god
you're blasting him he were blasting he
was just blasting he was blasting the
wi-fi
throw the subject off hardcore we're
doing some crazy [__] with the hardcore
right what breeding with the hardcore on
all the new all we're doing a hardcore
line with all the old-school [__]
hardcore og hardcore
okay and we're gonna bring that
[__] back alive like
because look at it the first time i
could never remember you ready when i
started hanging out with you guys yeah
jared and um when i just got the cousins
like yo here bam oh my god yeah and and
like he gave me like eight grams of [__]
back then it was like 110 bucks oh no it
was ridiculous i'm like did you just pay
my double my [__] like bills because
you're sad i'm broke [__] i'm just stop
selling packs i'm trying to [__] you
know i'm trying to just do the content
[__] i'm like did you oh my god yeah so
i was dabbing the hardcore rosie this is
when it happened
i thought okay
okay i was dabbing
i was 2014. i'm dabbing heavy heavy
heavy i've never told this story [__]
how about you forgot me i forgot about
this
so uh
hardcore i know you guys i'm dabbing you
guys are always smoking we're dabbing
the hardware and the hardcore batter
came out remember oh oh my god oh god
[__] that [__] it's so strong so i'm
dabbing it i'm at this push tree's house
and i go
like i'm having a [__] heart attack
oh my god i've never had a panic attack
before oh my god i passed out on a
[__] dab because it was the hardcore
the hardcore was so [__] violently
strong yeah i'm sitting there going
rosie rosie rose rosie what was it like
a good five six weeks i stopped dabbing
because every time i dabbed i started
having panic attacks and i thought i was
losing my breath
because i'm like am i i am fat but am i
that fat [__] that's why i kept thinking
and i started trying to like yo no more
no more [__] smoking i stopped
dabbing for like [__] three weeks
four weeks at least
and then after you know that she gets
fired bro there was a time where i told
rosie get the keys because if i said get
the keys i'm gonna take me to the
hospital yeah
and i never want to go hospital because
it scares me yeah so i go get the keys
take him to the hospital and then one
time the closest we got we opened the
door and went
i think i'm fine
and then i told jared i think he might
be on camera yeah i think i have it on
camera um
i go to the can one of the cannabis cups
cheers i go to one of the cannabis cups
and i tell him i'm like yo what the [__]
i thought i was having a heart attack
what's going on and go stop stop what
you're saying
he goes and gets one of his workers and
he goes say it and i told him and he
goes oh
rookie cause i've been in hospital four
or five times already every time they
tell me get the [__] out of here he goes
uh the security guard knows me already
he's like yo oh you're back huh
he told me he's like i thought i was
dying yeah he's like i'm like you guys
skinny he goes you thought you're having
a heart attack i've been in the hospital
at least five times so i'm like he goes
dude it's the hardcore yeah it is like
yeah i thought my heart was offbeat but
i'm just
panicking and i was taking slab dabs all
day get you in a crazy anxiety to this
day it still does it's just that strain
for some reason
the heart poor yeah the heart
the hardcore
marty over
[__] marty where are we at marty
where are we at 107. oh we're doing
great right now good [__] yeah so yes
the hardcore used to give me panic
attacks i was having a heart attack yeah
told him and he goes yeah that's just
the hardcore yeah that's strong
wow no the hardcore watch oh that's not
fun yeah but now that i know how to
handle it yeah
you're right
but yeah i remember when he said like
that's common like [__] that [__] so
that's when i met you guys so now now
you're teamed up yeah so now we're just
getting even better yeah so this is
grown by you
actually this not yet soon got you guys
soon soon wow so now so you're
announcing it i'm an altitude
oh you know
yeah i thought at first
but i love that because that goes in
line with like what we did and i think
for a lot of people like when you end up
stumbling into something that's like
when great [__] happens yeah you might
have had a whole run that you could have
already looked at and been like damn i'm
that dude over there right but then you
bump into another [__] you might
have had two runs yeah and he had a run
but now the timing came the timing's
right and both of you together make
something great oh my it it it's
beautiful bro
i mean all the [__] that me and my bro
been through and this kid is just on
fire right now
and then we come from the same
you know what i mean it's not like i'm
[__] partnering up with [__] some
[__] corporate [__] has the
cash right right 100 no this kid [__]
loves the plant yeah
we my brother loves a plant and that's
all that [__] matters and we want to
give it to the [__] people the good
and the
this is crazy yeah yeah because oh this
is
the dream team the pope put this team
together the pope
i i i don't want to mention his name but
he's the pope of wcc so he's the shout
out to my friend our friend nick
gonzalez too over there at wcc but
there's wcc means west coast care for
everybody out there yeah just making
sure yeah yeah west coast kid damn dude
that's crazy so you're bringing the
heart oh we're bringing the heart
[__] anxiety
a heart attack
you're a real dude
[__] anxiety yeah
and it's just a picture of you guys
looking stressed on the front
[Laughter]
or like those commercials where there's
pain
of the [__] mannequin this is a dude
that's me i give you the rights
you guys do this geriatric i've fallen
and i can't get up commercials
about the hardcore but it's just a dude
i'm [__] dying
i can't get up you know what i mean like
i dab and i'm [__] having a panic
attack
so you know
as long as you know marty i forgot to
tell you that i used to have panic
attacks
bad off dabbing and i stopped but then i
realized like yo red does not mean go
yeah i was titanium red nailing slabs of
hardcore it was back then [__] the
titanium it was affected from silica
silica glass
you can see my [__] silica rich too
no i found some of the other days so
[__] funny uh the uh hawaii uh
kool-aid man the kool-aid man remember
that he got sued immediately off that
[__]
probably i think so okay off the record
i had a kool-aid man he smiled
down quick [__] he smoked through his
hand and he dab at his other hand
sick
man i wish we had one of those right now
i know i gave it to my [__] brother
did you still have it i'm probably not
yeah i know he's not good with glass no
but i just gave it i when i moved i gave
away all my glasses i'm like no i can't
i can't just carry all this [__] for the
rest of my life [__] that i keep my ones
i just keep because you know you've got
a thousand toys in your living room
from the mask and if i could smoke out
of it i would
oh god come on you just gave him a
[__] an idea for this yeah
[Applause]
you're from out there do you ever been
to frank and sons the toy store do you
know about it
it's in pomona
pomona i would know about it frank it
says brightpearl i thought it was promo
that's my ass ah frankenstein where's
that at
it's a toy store it's science costco no
way i've only heard of toys r us bro
it's huge but it's different it's a
cannabis cup for toys you walk in and
there's different booths different
vendors and they stay there they're
stationary they don't move
like it's only open certain days a week
wow
i need to try that it's so [__] real
roland heights [__] that's close to us
it's [__] incredible sorry i i just i
keep i keep just dropping too much of
these places yeah i found something so
much so much sick [__] look at his face
i've been getting
this tables worth of like [__] from the
70s and 90s and just cool stuff
american psycho and jim carrey
yeah there we go but yeah silicon piece
sorry off track silicon pieces taking
red hot dabs
titanium nails yeah but that [__] would
ruin me that's when you get panic
attacks and anxiety but that's what was
happening to me back yeah we didn't know
better yeah you're lucky if everybody
started dabbing recently you're [__]
lucky
you're real lucky this is like when
people had to use crank cars and like
you people with a stick shift yeah yeah
that's obsessed right now i didn't even
know the temperature was a [__]
issue
did we even heat like when we eat the
titan back then we didn't give a [__] no
we heated that thing up but as soon as
the red yes it turned red i stopped and
start dabbing yeah yeah
red means yeah yeah
that's what you used to say red means
gold now we got the temperature [__]
now i got
i'm not a glass collector but we are
definitely [__] dab heads yeah you
guys have a dab right
we have to push trees when i'll give it
to you okay leave please don't let me
forget okay [__] bug
yeah but we do i we i [__] love dabs
so there's nothing like you know long
day getting home and taking one or two
and you're just [__] a little cooked
of course yeah a long day of i was gonna
say
you know it's a big difference with
smoking
uh trees all day for sure and then you
get home and you take one or two down
it's a [__] wrap yeah it's not cut
you want to get cooked or not
you want to get cooked or not you want
to smoke this it's true yeah that's true
so hold on
how do you like life
behind the desk
i got to ask tonight i know you're
saying well now i'm just doing this but
how do you like it right now i [__]
love it man yeah spending a lot of time
with you know at the pad with kids
[__]
but you know it's not gonna last too
long because once
it goes i'm gone
like you're gonna be going full force
full force 100 for the next [__]
five to eight ten years
waiting for i'm not stopping good [__]
i'm not stopping this is the opportunity
man this is the opportunity you guys
been building up for yeah we have a plan
there was a plan you know what i mean so
trent had a great question is the
thought of like a fully automated system
is that like a reality for a major not
for large cultivation there's a lot of
automated shift from the irrigation from
you know what i mean but at large scale
you have to have a you gotta you gotta
you gotta see those plants every [__]
day every minute you know what i mean
cause something to curve [__] then
[__] the room go you could lose the root
yeah yeah it could be all bad mm-hmm
yeah you ever lost a whole room oh [__]
yeah tons of times
oh
we frightened 60 i bet you sold it still
this is 2015 let me just tell you a
quick story [__] 60 light room we're
out in washington right [__]
right right the plants look good [__]
we [__] ended up
suffering the room back then you had the
sulphur was in the k was in the uh
you know in the can you put the sulfur
in it you [__] warm it up it [__]
leaves off some smoke
one of the guys forgot to [__] turn
the [__] lights the the lights off or
something
we come back in the next day sulfur's
[__] going lights are on fri plants
are just [__] cooked
yeah if you asked if i lost the whole
room i lost several rooms
oh on different [__] locations
how about flooding a room how about
fires you name it for real fires did you
at least try to smoke it no it was done
i mean like inhale the smoke
no it burned it
a light ended up busting right fell down
to a four into a four by eight tray
caught the tray on fire
plants went up
plastic tray went lit
the sprinkler [__] thing kicked on
and put out the fire
damn but we couldn't shut off the
sprinkler system right so if this is in
la one time
trip out on this
my brother gets a call we had for
24-hour security a spot in la he kept
calls my brother and tells him hey one
of the monitors one of the rooms looks
real foggy
right and my brother [__] panics
jumps up out of bed this is one in the
morning flies down there
the [__] waters just blowing there
was a fire
caught the tray the sprinkler thing [__]
the sprinkler head went off
at that time
we knew if we had a fire automatically
it sends to the fire department it's
called a flow switch on the on the on
the main riser right we disconnected it
smart right disconnected it if a
situation happened like this so by the
time i roll in
i'm pulling up to the front of the
[__] building there's [__] four or
five inches of water coming right out of
the [__] building
the whole place is just [__] flooded
my brother finally shut the [__]
valve off and shut the water but but the
whole building didn't go on fire and we
didn't get busted
but we lost the whole veg we lost a
flowering room we lost some [__] and
the reason why just because there's
water like it's plants it loves water
it's because you're mimicking the sun
and the summertime correct so you can't
it doesn't rain in the summer like that
so when the plants get [__] drenched
when they're flowering like what the
[__] world is this drone a planet smoke
and black smoke oh this is the fire
black smoke killed it
killed everything would you say weed
plants are really sensitive it's hard to
[__] them up or is it easy to [__] with
yeah it's real easy yeah from a grower
from crazy no it talking interaction
music all that [__] matters yeah real
easy to [__] [__] up mm-hmm
yeah correct yeah no you say all that
matters talking to you oh everything
matters bumping music do you put in your
in your rooms oh i'll put some led
zepplin
cool
elongated nine-minute songs i'll put
some young golf oh [__] i ain't gonna
[__] around i look yeah
oh [__] your plans are jumping
they're all hyped
that's no lie that's funny that's all
i've been listening to all day yeah you
posted my story earlier right no i loved
all that
yeah that's not good i think so
i hope you're not right
[__] it's been a long day man i've been
filming and [__]
damn okay so you're so that [__] really
matters you can't just ignore your rooms
you have to be that's what you're saying
no no
i mean irrigation everything's
definitely automated that's fine water
in the plants is all all amazing you
just press it in all the tubes oh yeah
yeah boom boom boom the whole room gets
water you have to have that for sure at
that large scale it's the nutrients and
the light what's the other factor is you
have the nutrition
and nutrients and the
the room temperature is all factors big
factors are you changing the room
temperature of course as the plants grow
grow your different weeks different yeah
those rooms got to be dialed into a t
bro and strains specifically oh and
strings because some strains are very
finicky and [__] right yep what's the
hardest [__] you ever grow in your life
what's the worst well i'm going to tell
you the hardest honestly he's probably
og kush i knew you're going to say it i
already knew really the sensitive heads
dude right
the fire og the og kush that we had was
[__] a [__] to [__] cut
to make clones
so we made extra i did [__] i don't know
maybe i was [__] up but it was always
a finicky [__] [__]
yep listen i'm simple you got a male i'm
simple you got a female plant right yeah
martin doesn't know this is for all
these simple
listeners out there those questions
please
okay now you got to crossbreed these
things yes to get to further the plants
yes what is that step what is the first
[__] long process
you got to pull the paul in you you to
for the plant to breed you have a male
and a female yes it can breed by itself
you know a male
kicks off pollen it's going to catch the
female as long as you do it at the right
time the right cycles right
but
uh if you're
if you're doing it you you got you could
pull paul different ways of reading the
plan it does it doesn't just happen
naturally in the grow rooms right no no
no you you have to plan it out you know
what i mean but it does it happen
naturally out there
in the wild
yes
it longs the male and the female at the
right times yes when it kicks off pollen
and that females at three four weeks
[__] it's ready to breathe
it's so crazy it's got a little life
it's so long to keep to get the right
when you when you breed and you cross
and do it takes a year year and a half
to get the the good results
really yeah say we crossed the resin
crusher to the runts right
oh the i love the resin crusher soursome
the it's as shiny as this
yeah oh it's it's i've never heard of
these it's just strange range that yeah
oh that's coming all that's coming soon
man but but back to the [__] it are you
threw me off it's my bad my bad you're
the resin crusher here we say you're
crossing it and there's really hard to
plant takes a year and a half at least
you get to get the right yeah it takes
it takes the time you ain't getting it
overnight and what you're saying is to
get and correct me i'm obviously
probably wrong here when you say to get
it right to get the seeds right to get
the seeds right to then plant yeah yep
and by right you mean i did this grow
didn't like plant number 34. number 34
was this oh that's that's beetle honey
that's fine that's different that's
different that's different so you're
just breeding the plants to make the
seeds say you want to say you like the
resin crust you got the resin crusher
and you got [__] the hardcore right
and now we want to make we want to put
these together yeah i got to pull paul
in from [__] this hardcore pulling
pollen pulling pollen and i'm going to
hit this resin crusher at three weeks in
flowering
and then we're going to make babies
right we're making babies now those
seeds are going to make take time we're
going to get those seeds and we're going
to plant those seeds and see if
everything comes out right and then
that's
you know you get you get your baby
that's yeah i didn't i didn't i knew
that had to take place but i didn't know
if you were sitting there manually doing
it oh yeah definitely definitely badly
really doing it yeah dude there's so
much to grow like that [__] i was
confused still yeah [__] i love weave
yeah it's just still confusing to me
yeah it's not easy
nah man i try to grow weed once
yeah that's why i posted the other day
what are the odds of this yesterday i
posted a nugget and i put artwork with
yeah with this emoji the artwork emoji
yeah very very good
an hour minutes later i didn't even know
he just posts the action this actual
artwork and it's his same post artwork
with the same [__] emoji we're all in
the same [__]
page
but i say that because it is that to me
i look at that [__] like somebody really
put their [__] it's like i'm a
graphic artist yeah somebody put their
spin on this yes this is our take on
this the [__] we're smoking now somebody
took a lot of time to [__]
do that you know what i mean it's a trip
dude i take it for granted because i
wear them from i'm so packed like yeah a
grower give me a better price i don't
care you know that's how it was like no
that's too much and it's like no
[__] i spent three weeks three
months with this [__] yeah i
want the price that i want and then i
didn't get it back then when i was
selling packs and [__] and then now as i
got older and started meeting and
growing and i know more people like nah
bro this is my working plan i played
like you playing music all day
yeah [__] yeah
leave it on when i leave it's on yep yep
wow you guys really care about this [__]
and then i started seeing it because i
never met a girl if i met a grower yeah
back where i'm from meaning you men you
didn't even meet the girl you met the
guy before but yeah if i met a grower i
bought a house
i didn't meet a grower i've never been a
grower before except for five like six
like
hiding it in their house and merced yeah
so now that i meet more people i get it
like oh you guys are you guys give a
[__] and that's what you're charging me
yeah
yeah now i understand because it's a
it's a it's a it's an artwork almost
yeah yeah i grew up buying two for fives
and [__] yeah
two for five what does that mean two
what two nugs two shitty little nickel
bags for five for five dollars oh yeah
two for five you've got two nickel bags
for that so you mean a ten
a ten ten but you're getting a half off
yeah
five you're getting two little shitty
why wouldn't they just make a five
pounds five seconds well i used to buy
the diamondbacks
the quantity
oh yeah
i'm going to flatten this nug a little
bit make it feel the bag and then it it
would look hefty yeah right it would
look empty in that thing you wouldn't
even question it i need two of those
three of those i got a question one time
in high school but i didn't have a scale
just eyeball like
try to form it try to form it yeah
that's it that's all i would try to do
to make it fatter try to fluff it at the
end and only the corners are empty you
know yeah yeah yeah of course
man i'm so happy you guys had to go
through this [__] for sure i didn't get
a prescription bottle until i was a
grown man prescription bottles were
crazy back then
you know if someone had a prescription
bottle a wee like this [__]
smokes yeah yeah yeah remember that i
was bragging i went to cali i'm like
they all had prescription bottles and
[__]
oh yeah dude so when you're selling
packs uh 2010 long ass time ago are you
selling packs to the clubs too
i would say at about 2 000
yeah 2013 12 yeah we were dealing with
dispensaries gtr was my our our two they
sound so familiar oh gtr was that why
that sounds so familiar they had about
[__] 20 stories these [__] asians
didn't play no games why why they sound
mad familiar gtr had [__] stores
throughout santa ana orange county
l.a you [__] they took all they took
our whole harvest
when i when we harvested out of p-town
that it went straight to gtr really i
would go i would walk out with 100 bands
every time damn oh yeah 96 bands [__]
hundred bands every time oh and they
would be gone and they would want more
because
that that whatever i was taking at that
time 20 40 pounds
it it it got distributed to two through
20 swords oh
you feel me it's not just walmart yeah
yep and they were the they were the
walmart of dispensary gtr they didn't
play games mom and pop selling a brand
at walmart yeah yeah did did you do i
see i live in orange county so my whole
first experience with legal weed was the
little bro mom and pop shops in orange
county in 2014 2015
oh it was guaranteed owned by gtr mm-hmm
yup yeah that was the [__] oh 100 it
sounds so familiar i feel like oh you
don't i i feel like i know kevin you
don't know kevin [__] he would look at
them mr nice guys in santa ana too
probably
why does gtr sound so for me gtr what
did that stand for baby remember she
[__] work for gta
yeah used to go into like an office
building and there'd be [__] 10
different little offices with different
little [__] oh man they were the plug
bro really every man it was so smooth
for years just so smooth did they not
cross over into their oh yeah i'm pretty
sure they did yeah yeah they did
definitely crossed over yeah did they
used to write your name down yeah he
brought so many these down he brought
these he came out so many of this well
kevin was the uh let me see it didn't
feel weird when they're like what's your
name like
that first time
no it was just cash [__] it but they
didn't write your name down and say this
the guy brought this many packs today no
they never did never wrote nothing time
i wrote my only time i sold packs to
some dispensaries like
yeah like fifteen times no they never
[__] no i was for my name and gave me
a receipt oh no [__] no these guys
because they knew what time it was okay
like a fake last but here's my first
thomas garcia
garcia yeah that's garcia's so cool yeah
yeah [__] thomas garcia john smith
oh you look like a giant
oh my god
damn what the [__] are you talking about
oh yeah selling the [__] dispensers
yeah but yeah i was those were the good
old [__] days they didn't play no
game it was so cool
i would drive with [__] two duffel
bags [__] full of weed
yup straight there so you were [__]
pissed when things went more corporate
on that side
actually
it it was like i wasn't more pissed i
was like okay
we got to shut down the traps right we
got to to do this thing in 2018 when we
went to honolulu so we took a a a loss
of good money coming in right to support
the family or whatever we were doing
good excellent money right
when we went that legal side we sold
everything bro
we got rid of all the traps that went to
this legal side and went put everything
that we had into this legal side
and took a little loss they didn't pay
you know [__] took a big loss but
it was a right if you wanted to do this
and do it the right way and not get in
trouble and yeah you know at my age this
is what i want to do for a living you
know it's your career
so if i can get a [__] good paycheck
or a good legal money coming in i'm i'm
i'm all for it oh yeah so that's what we
did we sold we shut down everything and
with this legal side right
and it was super hard
super hard bro
the the the good money wasn't you know
but hey we took a sacrifice and we did
it you know what i mean and
oh yeah you know it didn't work out so
good at that route but look where i'm at
today
[Music]
yeah these look good man yeah pre-rolls
oh excellent thank you cool cool uh cool
packaging too yeah thank you you won't
break that [__] oh what do we have
marty
[__] 30. i knew it i'll say 128. what
what's happening i'm asking what times
are we at oh okay yeah this is just
animation
words
yeah that's trying to make sure where
are we at where are we at what time we
at
um
yeah man so this is this is the next
step for you that's what i really wanted
for me and my brother yeah next step
next step ours is our future for the
next 10 years
locked in [__] done
i'm [__] sure that [__] feels good
oh marty
i could breathe bro i don't drive around
with 10 packs no more trying to pay the
bills oh when you see a copy driver oh
no pull me over
isn't the weirdest feeling ever though
it's the first time it happens like yeah
well bro wow is this how everybody else
feels i'm just super stoked to uh
to be where i'm at me and my bro my
sister me and me watching you yeah me
seeing you guys i've known you guys for
a long time man yeah so i remember you
guys just trapping it out trapping it
out trapping it out and when legal
yeah
and we tried it first in washington
2015.
and we were out there for almost two
years and that didn't work out
but
it we learned so [__] much
you know from testing the [__] this
that you name it we learned so much got
back down here right
and then
trapped it for a little bit and then
went went to the legal side
it was it's a transition man it's a
crazy transition i'm happy that you came
in here because i wanted to see and show
people
both sides of the of the market you're
getting both sides of
this yeah from
terence to pioneer yeah the balance beam
you know what i'm saying and that's why
i wanted to ask about your children
later like you're doing all of this and
running a platoon yeah
yeah man you're crushing it you're doing
a lot you guys can run full court yeah
we can work full court of course
you know you know i i got the best coach
on the planet the best helper my best
supporter is queen and if i didn't have
her bro then none of that [__] would
happen yeah you have to have that
you guys can't hear it he's doing sirens
yeah
if you didn't
that support getting home after a long
day and dinners keeping [__] ready yeah
keep the house [__] maintain your
clothes like it's hard to run a [__]
household bro i don't know dude it's
it's it's [__] hard rosie both try to
balance out
queen
is
keep the one that keeps me [__] going
i [__] [__]
well now now now
you have a whole stress lifted off you
too man yeah now you know
you're good oh [__]
the smile yeah yeah i get it i see it
yeah you're yeah very cool super happy i
think i even gave you some weight ah i
gained like 10 pounds i was like [__]
the [__] i better start my hikes man
[__] oh [__] but you know [__] i'm
living yeah i'm living you're [__]
you have to wear it do you need to dress
how you want oh oh i dressed with the
one oh okay over there
yeah [__] they look they they love it
it's what they love it they love they
want you yeah yeah yeah they love it of
course they love it it's crazy to hear
in the corporate side of you guys now oh
our
the poster is so wild though like think
about it
did you think trapping the [__] out you
goes both would not eventually team up i
didn't think that would happen no
oh it's crazy because i was telling this
kid
we've always had a dream and we've
always kept in contact and
for some when we we did this deal we we
locked in with these guys right
i've always had a [__] vision with
with jared i don't know why
but i've had this vision that we're
gonna do something to get in the future
and [__] it happen
i told that to this kid [__] they
tripped out i go for some reason bro you
were
we just had a crazy vision and [__]
it happened and not everything has to be
rushed yeah and it takes time for
yourself a lot of time yeah
good things take time man
i'm glad i'm glad this is this is going
to be
you guys work math yes
everywhere yeah yeah it's gonna be super
i love that you've had a whole career
you've done all this yeah og in this
whole space yeah it's like now i'm
really just getting started and i'm
dialed in i'm about to go ham this next
time yeah next five [__] crazy next
five ten years that's what we never say
right now about this [__] it's about to
start yeah it's barely beginning
my life is barely [__] beginning like
yeah
hell yeah
you know what i mean [__]
good [__] i could breathe yeah and you
don't have to worry no more no no
worries oh man yeah good i'm so glad to
hear that man
[__] super [__] stupid good dude
thanks for having me [__] button this
is
yeah
all right so congrats dude so everybody
thank you for support west coast go to
west coast yes west coast school you
guys see it in the shops not right we
can't sit here and [__] name [__]
because youtube it's
awesome [__] with us but
we love you though don't worry yeah uh
west coast secure that's how you just
support all right
um i'm excited that you guys are
introducing your strains and now it gets
to go to everybody yes everybody is that
resin crusher like i said earlier oh
that was called like silver surfer yeah
i love it it's [__] great crusher
sauer sandia pina grande the penal one
was wild that's the beast all that
it's coming and it's gonna be under
there
literally goal the size kids yeah
[__] nugs i saw it when you did that
look they're [__] massive i remember
yeah the last time i saw you guys you
guys were here remember yeah before we
built this room yeah we're sitting right
here yeah on the couch and we had to set
up this wasn't here it was over there on
the other side yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
the last time i saw you man
it's been a while yeah they've been
working yeah working good [__] though
thank you so what's uh where can
everybody find you on like uh instagram
instagram websites whatever you can find
me at by also grow all one word
p-a-y-a-s-o-g-r-o-w gross we'll pop it
up yep plop it right here on the screen
yep and then you can follow the cannabis
gardener cannabis that's your brother
that's my brother
gardener
these are just pages like if you love
weed you should look at pages it's just
the process and the journey of plants
truly is what it is you guys should
check it out it's pretty it's pretty
[__] cool that's why you guys have
success because you guys always are this
is what we do it's never like yo
[__] uh a rapper kush comes out today
and you know i mean that [__] doesn't
happen right but you need a little bit
of that it doesn't have to be the whole
thing no that's not the most important
it's not the drive the back
yeah the first 80 going that shit's fire
as [__] that's what matters that's what
matters that's what always matters yeah
and i remember this oh i remember all
that [__] i remember that was the
boutique we that's the boutique ass weed
man that you've been searching for and
longing for this whole time oh but i i
remember the did you guys you guys we
was [__] i remember back then
especially when it was before we had to
go to markets the packs i think i'm
thinking about the packs because now you
have this oh my god
oh
all stick together like a [__]
football yeah like not in a bad way you
just want to push through the [__]
wall dude yeah
oh incredible yeah
but i'm excited to see you introduce
these trains so oh thank you um pay also
grows you can go to the cannabis
gardener yep and uh do you have websites
or anything uh no we don't but you can
go to west coast
support guys if you we're not saying to
go buy weed but if you happen to buy
weed
just remember
this guy that you got to watch and get
to know maybe hands-on [__] grow in
the weed that you're smoking right now
so that's the way to support all right
thank you guys pretty [__] cool thank
you it is it is it's pretty [__] cool
like i've never really grown me and
marty gonna smoke the weed that we're
growing it's [__] wild yeah that's
[__] dope right he's been doing like
i've never even done it i've never
smoked weed i grew up it's gonna be
[__] pretty cool man he's like a
farmer yeah
farmer farmer's market man yeah well
we're like hunters
we have a sedan forget it machine and
[__]
oh [__] thank you so much for coming too
thank you for having me
[__] honor man next time thank you
next time we'll have both of you guys
yeah yeah yeah definitely phil thank you
i love you brother
i just said thank you i appreciate this
one marty thank you
thank you thank you for bringing in the
mill of lights oh yeah i love you guys
appreciate it yeah thank you guys um
we're gonna hop out of here marty thank
you appreciate you oh yeah thank you
martin light soundboard today i noticed
oh yeah yeah you know when to come in
yeah
yeah i don't know you watch so you know
he hits [__] sound boys i know
you watch the show i like to bring it
out when people are super [__] up off
mushrooms and [__]
yeah i got mushrooms for you next one oh
[__] okay there we go yeah i don't even
know what kind of mushrooms oh my god
i'm a little nervous to take [__] you
take no she's because she's i know what
you smoke yeah
i [__] should have brought this
liquid next time yeah next time yeah
this liquid stay tuned
or drink some shell oh man
um
sorry oh yeah my bad i was just thinking
about mushrooms i was facing out
thinking it looked like mushrooms i was
thinking about vials and droppers in my
head brown bottles and black lids
all of that was
thanks for coming thank you for being
here marty thank you for being here
thank you sir thank you appreciate you
being here guys for everyone out there
thank you so much for hanging out thank
you for
just getting to know getting to know
piazza getting no turrets yeah all right
getting to know all right this has been
words from the halfway down
but yeah
my bad but
i didn't even associate anything to
someone what do you mean
gotcha i got you right now sorry i
didn't understand i'm [__] it's the
miller lights it's the million lights
yeah we might be [__] up yeah the
brewing company yeah milwaukee wisconsin
we're drinking responsibly drinking
responsibly we're getting good at these
athletes in our head that was not
necessary but we did good right now
all right thank you so much for being
here dude appreciate you guys
until next time this has been the dopes
usual podcast and for marty i marty
terence and i have a dope ass day i'm
i'm hot for everybody out there i was
literally filming a
weed video before we even started yeah
so how was that [__] high how was
that what
this yeah [__] awesome
[Music]